deswegen habe ich nicht bekommen hat man
damals luca und meine damen und herren
ihr seht es bereits eingeblendet jude
und ich hoffe wir uns heute produkte die
und als kind immer verboten wurden also
von den eltern muss sonst dafür werden
die beiden gleich zum tierarzt fahren
dieses videos nicht gesponsert wir
werden die ganze sache natürlich selbst
kaufen mit unserem eigenen geld so wie
ich wird die uns kaufen will hat er kein
geld bewertet fahren und werden uns so
langsam warum schauen wir haben schon
ein paar sachen in notizen abgeschrieben
also ein paar produkte die zb ich immer
mal haben wollte als kind aber wirklich
nie bekommen habe aber ich würde sagen
wir sehen uns jetzt erstmal beim tus
erst wieder hieß es meine damen und
herren mit jule hier sind einfach so
blutspuren auf dem boden platz einen
daumen hoch da ich durfte halt nie
solche masken haben weil die immer so
gewaltsam waren das wollte meine eltern
nicht dass sogar ein messer bei nice
alter jetzt was was wir gebrauchen
könnte ein scheiß hattet ihr früher auf
den kaufmannsladen also meine schwester
hatte ein ich hab den immer mit
benutzten und hat mir diese ganzen
sachen und es war schon ganz geil aber
60 euro ist wichtig wäre das hier ja wir
wollten endlich polly pocket raus weil
über meinte dass sie das nicht oft aber
aber das ist dass es so ähnlich solche
kleinen steuerbaren fliegenden
helikopter durfte ich nie haben
ich glaube meine eltern hatten angst
habe ich meiner schwester gegen kopf
fliege oder sowie sind sie bei den
süßigkeiten angekommen und werden jetzt
noch so einiges einpacken
ich wollte eigentlich alles
wer einkaufen aber wir haben hier so
krank und fast papier sachen eingekauft
über 100 euro ausgegeben
deswegen zeigt nicht richtig ganze sache
jetzt einfach wieder damit zu hause sind
tatsächlich unfassbar viele sachen ja
eingekauft erfassung für das komische
licht aber es ist ein bisschen später
geworden gestand noch mitten im stau
aber ich hätte echt nicht gedacht dass
ich so viele sachen findet die ich als
kind verboten bekommen habe sagt mal
leider haben wir auch einige sachen die
ich mir vorher in ihre tiefsten
geschrieben habe wirklich nicht gefunden
wie beispielsweise sonne juli module des
oder so hieß es glaube ich
die bringt haben oder pokédex wollte ich
früher auch modelle haben die luft sich
auch nie haben ja ich nicht als
allererstes meine damen und herren
kommen wir zu einem produkte was glaube
ich kein kind zu wirklich trinken durfte
uns war red bull energy drink die sache
ist dadurch dass meine eltern mir
wirklich die ganze zeit gesagt haben du
darfst nicht trinken macht dies auch
einfach nicht energy drink ist ja gerade
so ein bisschen die debatte ob das
überhaupt erst sogar erst 18 glaube ich
zu kaufen sein darf in deutschen
supermärkten et cetera pp aber einer die
drinks durfte ich als kind nie trinken
meine eltern müssen wir auch jetzt habe
ich noch verbieten denn sie können das
nächste produkt was wir ebenfalls nicht
und äußerst gerade gekauft haben was war
meine eltern ebenfalls verboten haben
war eine playstation
ich durfte ich hab eine playstation 3
bekommen aber nachdem ich sechs jahre
lang oder so gebettelt habe beherrschen
habe ich mit auf jeden fall selbst von
meinem eigenen geld gekauft deswegen
playstation habe ich auf jeden fall und
die nächste sache ist etwas was jule als
kind zwar auch hatte aber ich glaube das
ist dann zu viel davon und dann wird sie
verboten noch mehr davon zu kaufen
konnte man auch so anzieht hatte sony
das flugzeug der vorherigen teil auf
welches beim auspacken ja denn der maler
der kann auch war er in rotterdam fahren
während judith ihren polly pocket said
von ba wieder auspacken die nächste
sache die ich auch nie haben durfte
waren so schief sachen sagen die dürfen
oder zu sehen ist wenn aus der
entfernung mit nerd et cetera wurden wir
auf jeden fall ist verboten weil das mit
schiefen zu tun hatte und ich durfte
auch als ich 16 war noch nicht
irgendwelche ansatzweise kriegsspiele
spielen soll es meinem vater immer
genannt und dabei hat es mir natürlich
mega abgefangen hat immer so heimlich
irgendwelche spieler 16 oder 18 gespielt
ich durfte das halt nie und ich wollte
halt alles immer zeichnen meinen eltern
gegenüber offen halten ich glaube das
ist aber die richtige erziehungsmethode
war und ich glaube ich werde mein team
dann auch alles verbieten
die nächste sagt meine damen und herren
ist tatsächlich etwas sehr sehr sehr
sehr großen satz gekaufter besteht
nämlich eine popcornmaschine juni
wollten kunden kaufen und habe ich
tatsächlich nie gefallen korn alter
popcorn oder schoko boden hier ist eine
abstimmung oder schreibt kommentare
das ist ganz toll kommt sieht auch das
schaffe es nicht weil wir bauen das
nicht auf wir zeigen euch nur die sachen
die wir mal eben gekauft haben und ich
leute das video wird er so lange wir
haben wir haben so viele sachen kaufte
vor komplett hohl die tüte popcorn
maschine wurden auf jeden fall auch
immer verboten
was das denn das hier ist das was wir
gerade in der hand hatte sowas wurde mir
tatsächlich auch immer verboten weil das
zu gewaltsamen war sagt ich mache ich
auch wünschen gesagt das waren einem das
hier seine tricks was das finden wir
sind ja sonst hätten deswegen halloween
keine ahnung war es meine eltern wollten
glaube ich einfach nie dass ich eine
falsche richtung hab trifft oder so und
haben wir sowas nie erlaubt aber ich
habe auch selber angst vor
vielleicht kommt daher weil die nächste
sache die wir haben sind süßigkeiten
freunde das sind diese gar nicht war das
von dir ja also das sind solche klubs
natürlich den ich die also sehen diese
teile hier aus wenn man das denn
badens wieder wenn ich das jetzt echt
gut richtig gut
wieso wurde uns das nicht erlaubt sein
rocker auch richtig gesund
eine weitere süßigkeit die uns war in
beiden nie erlaubt wurde wie war ehrlich
dürfte es manchmal aber ich habe
insgesamt nur dreimal so wird gefährlich
strichliste sorbet gefühl das ist dieses
glaube mir aus der tube also man kann
sich das einfach so raus pusten wie
sonne das jetzt auch so ein bisschen auf
die zahnpasta
aber es ist kaugummi aus der tube so
sieht das hier aus so kommt dass daraus
und ich würde sagen würde
ich will das nicht essen das riecht nach
autoreifen so ein bisschen finde ich wie
kannst du denn das so feiern
cool wieder stimmt also kein scheiß ich
weiß nicht wie ich das als kind wollte
ich habe es halt nie irgendwie probiert
oder so weil keiner durfte das irgendwie
das nächste ist etwas was keine
flüssigkeit ist es ist einfach ein
knicklicht habe ich teilweise verboten
bekommen zwar immer so dass wir das halt
an geburtstagen oder silvester oder so
klar hat meine mutter dann prüfen die
knicklichter gekauft um halten deshalb
genügend zu teleportieren sodass sie
werden allerdings waren meine eltern
auch dort glaube ich sehr vorsichtig
weil das ausspritzen könne als wichtiger
instant ich glaube meine eltern undercut
vorsichtig dass es nicht auf spritzt und
dann irgendwie augen kommen sodass oder
weil das ergibt sich dann die nächste
sache die wir haben ist wieder von jule
und zwar es ist ein kinder überraschungs
maxi du bist hast überhaupt schon so
lange ja das gibt's nur verlangen und
ich hoffe es nicht haben wenn meine
mutter immer noch leute was ist
eigentlich euer lieblings kinderladen
dingen bei mir unglaublich kinder bohème
oder kinder countries auch aber
kinderriegel das schiebe ich halt so
eine paranoia drauf weil meine oma mir
das immer geschenkt da waren irgendwann
mal abgelaufen
die größte volltrottel die das nicht
hingekriegt habe ein riesen ja das habe
ich tatsächlich früher man mit meiner
schwester gemacht die luft über die
schokolade ist und ich hab die
spielzeuge bekommen ich meine schokolade
halt einfach nicht so krass juli kommt
kann sache alles aufessen aber jetzt mit
mir hier drehen doch weitermachen bei
julia hinten ihr kinderschokolade ging's
weiter essen mülheim schön was man
ebenfalls nicht verboten wurde sag ich
mal aber was mir nach derzeit verboten
wurde weil ich zu viel davon hatte
wachen hot wheels also diese kleinen
fahrzeuge diese kleinen autos und das
tier war so sind typischen standard
model karen so autos die man einfach nie
auf der straße sehen würde also verendet
war alter alter ging ja schnell
ok so krass beim hot wheels für noch
nicht aber naja ok das war auf jeden
fall das rote auto meine damen und
herren
wie gesagt wurde mir nicht direkt
verboten ich hatte auch mal heftige bahn
aber irgendwann hatte ich halt 20 30
familien karren und zwei drei bahnen und
dann wird meine eltern aber ein bisschen
zuviel karosserie bei mir im zimmer als
nächstes machen wir weiter mit einer
weiteren süßigkeit und war dem power
schocks kränkelt handy bei mir das immer
so ich hatte diese kranke die die kräfte
ich hatte mal crack als kind wir hatten
an ostern immer so schokolade die man
dann essen konnte und dann hat im mund
gekribbelt und ich dachte wirklich alles
erst mal gegessen habe dass ich ganz
viele folien mit gegessen hätte das
alles ausgesprochen das hat nicht
aufgehört und dann das wer todkrank oder
so das sind alles sachen die man als
kind unbedingt wollte
mittlerweile irgendwie weist also die
jugend feiert das immer noch da gibt es
grün und rot ich würde sagen ich nehme
rote zunächst ein grünes das selber
todesraser franchise freunde diese
ließen die powershot keine ahnung was
diesen kranken dass das erste mal ist
mir jetzt gerade wirklich sonstigen rein
gepfiffen haben die nächste sache mit
der wir weiter machen meine damen und
herren ist etwas von dem ich irgendwann
wirklich viel zu viel hatte meine eltern
auch ein hey du hast doch schon genug et
cetera pp die haben aber den sinn
dahinter nicht verstanden und zwei yukio
sammelkarten hier das sind irgendwie so
neue paten ich weiß nicht also ich kenne
das monster nicht was da drauf ist aber
ich glaube alle jungs unter euch werden
junior noch kennen das war so nice ich
hatte meine ersten karten irgendwie und
war glaube ich sechs karten oder so
waren normal und eine karte glänzen dann
habe ich alle sechs normalen karten
gegen eine glänzende karte von einem
kumpel getauscht
man habe ich meine glänzte karte gegen
zehn normale karten von ihm anders
getauscht anerkennung in der grundschule
das ist sogar die griechen die
kleiderkammer dabei geld obwohl mein
gott dies auch glänzend oder ist advent
er natürlich ist das glänzend gewünscht
ich bin ganz ehrlich freuen ich habe das
juwi ohne kartenspiel nie richtig
verstanden ich hatte immer nur die
sammelkarten hatte dann so ein prospekt
ihren sondern dina4 dingen was willst du
denn der hat so eine polit-talkshow ich
habe auf jeden fall richtig viele karten
und ein kumpel von mir hatte einfach den
wanzen drachen
das war die heftigste karte es gab noch
diesen zeiten wo man so ganz viele
verschiedene karten braucht so 2 für die
beine 2012 luca wir machen weiter die
nächste sache die wir uns gekauft habe
sind solche cool milch strohhalme mit
denen wenn man milch trinkt wird das zu
packen jetzt einfach mal alle drei teile
rein also wir haben hier viele erdbeeren
und schoko und ich würde sagen als
allererstes hast du dich mal schoko ich
möchte jetzt nicht die sonntag auer war
da schmeckt krass dass mac krass nach
krank und bin ich jetzt endlich wollte
ich als kind die haben kann ich auch nie
wirklich über diesen das ist so die
hatten in der pause auch immer so pausen
möglich kommt man sich entscheiden ob
man so will
genauso schmeckt das ist megageil er
besaß war es der die teile sind übel
hälfte ich als nächstes habe ich etwas
was neben wirklich komplett verboten
wurde das hatte ich nie durfte ich nie
haben weil ich damit glaube ich meiner
schwester gegen den kopf geflogen wäre
ich war halt wirklich so ein richtiges
tollpatsch kind das ist auf jeden fall
sondern als helikopter mit dem man
irgendwie so rum fliegen kann
ich habe deswegen hab ich nicht ob da
bekommt ja leute das war auf jeden fall
der helikopter
als nächstes haben wir hier tatsächlich
wieder eine süßigkeit herzinger termin
wenn jemand erst mal dass das hier also
wirklich freunde das ist einfach kurz
sogar
ich wollte so etwas auch nie das hat man
immer nur den serien regulieren
dann weißt du das rein menschlich
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend als nächstes
haben wir uns hier so ein spray gekauft
was man sich auf die zunge sprühen kann
dann haben wir da schmeckt ja nur
nachholer zwar hat auch so dieses
typische blutzucker denn genauso wie
diese was ist denn fini dollar davon wir
in einem wörterbuch das sei die höchste
was so völlig verloren
von diesem bericht gar nichts
200 euro was ich allerdings nicht nur
für meine damen und herren und das ist
wirklich das was mir immer immer
verboten wurde ist ein fetter wunderbar
sie vermissen die auf dem spiel
verlange ich durfte die immer war
eigentlich immer noch größer und nur der
beatclub die wahre größe macht man das
ist daran merkt man schon dass du es
nicht hat ist wir machen wir aber direkt
weiter freunde ihr merkt schon das bild
wird immer dunkler ist auf jeden fall
leid aber wir waren nicht lange zeit
haben viele sachen zusammen gesucht und
mir wird standort ehrlich gesagt lange
im stau eine nächste sache die mir
ebenfalls verboten wurde waren wrestling
figuren bzw allgemeiner wrestling
anschauen kleine story dazu das einzige
mal dass ich wirklich racing als kind
geschaut haben und sah mit meinem cousin
bei meiner oma lauda oder nicht auch mal
was die einzige die es erlaubt hat lässt
ihn zu gucken dass wir jetzt auf jeden
fall soll
figur daraus der 130 den kenne ich gar
nicht bei uns gab es seither undertaker
john cena
das ist auf jeden fall diese figur wurde
mir als kind allgemeinen komplett
verboten wrestling also auch boxsport
und so wird die ganze zeit schmeckt die
nächste und ich glaube auch letzte sache
tatsächlich die wir uns gekauft haben
wir sind jetzt hier bei den letzten
artikel so ein bisschen schneller durch
gegangen weil ich bin in der datei bei
30 minuten und sie haben etwas gefällt
es wie gedacht und die sonne
warum können winter nicht die sonder
auch später untergehen
seit der winter oder sind euch schreibt
in die kommentare meine damen und herren
wurden mir nicht verboten hatte ich aber
er war genauso wie bei den hot wheels
hatte ich dann mit der zeit einfach zu
viele rest was bei bild sind
woher hatte
du hattest auch bett dass mein kampf
machen an alle die es nicht kennen
das sind solche kreisel die braucht man
zusammen anpacken diese blaue
ladestation und hat dann quasi die sonne
zieht daran und dann kreise der reise
sich vor und ich glaube das war genauso
wie die hoch auf eine serie die auf rtl2
superrtl zwar noch cool war überlegen
mittlerweile läuft er noch so ich bin ja
nur noch so was läuft da nur noch vor
sich hatte auf jeden fall
ich würde sagen der beyblade da gehen
wir mal ins badezimmer testen denn auch
eben
also wir haben jetzt hätte ich freunde
mich wäre dass man nicht in meiner
spiele hier liegen die machen sondern
mich auf dem boden
nö abregen juli war das als kinder und
natürlich das platzen einer grundschule
cooler wenn wir das heutige video und
allerdings auch wenn ich meine damen und
herren wendet euch gefallen hat last auf
jeden fall leichter und wollt ihr dass
wir einen zweiten teil hiervon machen
weil dann würde ich mir sachen bei
amazon bestellen wie beispielsweise in
pokédex oder dieses jubiläums dinge also
noch mal ganz viele sachen die uns als
kind verboten wurde da gab es eine menge
sachen unsere kindheit war nämlich
richtig beschissen stimmt doch wirklich
nicht wert eine ganz schöne kindheit
aber auch ohne diese ganzen dinge sind
sehr dahin gekommen wo wir gerade sind
ich bin verzweifelt der youtuber und
jude schläft am tag 30 stunden vorher
das video gefallen welche dinge wurden
euch als kind verboten schreibt den
kommentaren
[Musik]